Як Україні вдається стримувати Росію?
Найпотужніша зброя країни - цифрові технології.
Наприклад, розвідка на основі штучного інтелекту, дрони та цифрові карти битв у реальному часі.
Усе це відіграє важливу роль для успіху України.
Ось три цифрові інструменти, які змінюють сучасну війну.
Інформація в режимі реального часу є важливою зброєю у війні.
Програмне забезпечення отримує дані з таких джерел, як GPS, супутники, камери спостереження,
дрони і навіть мобільні телефони.
Вони надають інформацію про сили противника та їхнє місцезнаходження.
Українські військові можуть користуватися цифровими картами поля бою на своєму планшеті чи смартфоні.
Штучний інтелект має вирішальне значення, коли йдеться про обробку великих обсягів даних
і їхнє практичне використання. Українська армія має для аналізу гори даних у реальному часі -
це інформація, яка може врятувати життя, якщо її досить швидко оцінити.
Штучний інтелект також може допомогти з оцінкою шкоди під час атак у режимі реального часу,
а в деяких випадках навіть передбачити, де ворог може нанести наступний удар.
Український стартап Zvook використовує програмне забезпечення для ідентифікації ракет,
гелікоптерів, винищувачів і дронів за допомогою звукової бази даних.
Обладнання складається з акустичних дзеркал і мікрофона.
Шум записується, а штучний інтелект ідентифікує джерело шуму шляхом порівняння.
Та навіть попереджає, коли атака неминуча.
Війну проти України назвали "першою кібервійною в історії планети".
Стефан Дуган, генеральний директор Інституту кібермиру, пояснює чому.
Ніколи раніше кібер не мав такого значення і такої ваги в контексті ведення війни.
Інформаційно-комунікаційні технології справді застосовуються усіма сторонами конфлікту
для досягнення військових цілей. Тобто це зміна правил гри.
Кібератаки вже зачепили 37 країн. Кіберпростір за своєю суттю безмежний.
Я думаю, саме тому це називається кібервійною, тому що вже набагато більше країн, окрім України та Росії,
постраждали від цих кібератак.
Українці технічно підковані: в країні працює понад 200 тисяч розробників програмного забезпечення.
Деякі з них разом з міжнародними ІТ-спеціалістами сформували "ІТ-Армію України" -
міжнародний колектив із понад 300 тисяч волонтерів, озброєних програмним забезпеченням.
Тепер хакери з обох сторін атакують критичну інфраструктуру.
Інститут кібермиру у Женеві зафіксував у 2022 році понад 850 кібератак,
пов’язаних з війною Росії проти України.
Більшість з них були так званими DOS-атаками або атаками на відмову в обслуговуванні.
Вони були спрямовані на паралізацію роботи банків, міністерств та цивільної інфраструктури.
Якщо подивитися на період із січня по вересень 2022 року, то різко зросла кількість атак на Україну.
Також є кампанія кібератак проти Росії, але кількість явно менша.
Тобто коли йдеться про Україну, ми зафіксували близько 1800 випадків.
А на Росію ми змогли задокументувати 150 кібернападів.
Цікаво, що хакери з "Анонімус", міжнародного колективу хакерів-активістів, борються по обидва боки:
"Анонімус Росія" пов’язана з понад сотнею атак, тоді як "Анонімус Україн"а здійснила близько 50 кібератак.
Експерти кажуть, що війна в Україні - це перша війна, в якій безпілотники
використовують в такому масштабі з обох сторін.
Їх використовують як зброю та для збору розвідданих.
Особливо коли йдеться про військову розвідку,
важливу роль відіграють цивільні дрони, створені для невійськових цілей.
Після заклику України донатити дрони люди з усього світу відправили безпілотники в Україну.
Тепер вони літають над російськими позиціями та військовими базами,
надаючи важливу інформацію українській армії.
"Аеророзвідка", приватний підрозділ, сформований після початку російської агресії у 2014 році,
який складається з колишніх IT-працівників і військовослужбовців,
навіть почав перетворювати цивільні дрони на військові пристрої, які можуть нести та скидати гранати.
Але Україна покладається не лише на саморобну зброю, коли йдеться про безпілотники.
Як бойові дрони служать турецькі безпілотники "Байрактар TБ-2" і американські Switchblade.
У той час як "Байрактар TБ-2" має величезний розмах крил - 12 метрів -
і може бути використаний повторно, Switchblade відомий як "дрон-камікадзе",
оскільки врізається в ціль, що робить його одноразовим.
Штучний інтелект, хакерські атаки та дрони - війна РФ проти України назавжди змінює правила ведення війни.
Як ви думаєте? Чи вирішать технології, хто переможе у цій війні?